- Let's say you were
dropped in the wilderness
and you can only pick
one of us to be with you,
to help you get through the wilderness.
- Oh, that's obvious.
- I mean, I think they're gonna
be boring, and they're gonna
pick each other.
- You're asking me this?
- [Kelly] But, like what
are you, who would you pick?
- I'd pick Blake and I would
kill him and take the vodka
in his back pocket.
(laughing)
(clapping)
'Cause I got news for ya,
you see his Starbucks
mug on "The Voice" right?
You all see that, it ain't coffee!
- [Kelly] It ain't coffee.
(audience laughing)
- I got news for you, so yeah.
- I don't know how y'all do
this job without drinking.
(laughing)
- I don't know how you do it drinking,
- I know.
- I would, whoa, it would be--
- I partake a little bit just enough.
(laughing)
- Yeah, little red wine for John.
- [John] Just enough.
- Oh I can't, I wouldn't,
I'm already crazy.
So, yeah.
Wait, who would you pick
on an island like if,
or wilderness, if you got
dropped in the wilderness,
and you just had to pick
one of us.
- Oh no,
I feel like Blake because he--
- [Kelly] What the hell!
- He's got all these--
(audience laughing)
- I am not useless!
- He's got all these acres of
ranch land in Oklahoma and--
- I have like seven thousand
acres of land as well!
- I feel like like he would know
a lot of "out-doorsy" things
that would get us through life over there.
- He'd also make a good raft!
(laughing)
- Kelly, you can't even
beat me on your own show.
- I can't even beat you on my own show!
- But, it's true!
I remember the first
time I went to Oklahoma
with my family, we are like from Anaheim
we'd never seen even trees
before so we were like,
"Wow! This is like crazy!"
And were like driving,
and Blake's in his truck,
and there's a tree that
had, like, been blown down
on the road and Blake
gets out and he's like,
"All right" and he gets
in the back of the truck
he has like-
- A chainsaw!
- A big chain, and he pulls it out,
he wraps it around the tree and like,
my whole family's like, "Oh my God!
"He's a man!" it was like--
(clapping)
(cheering)
- [Carson] Gwen, knew she was in love!
- So good answer.
- We do that,
my husband is kind of different
he pulls out a chainsaw!
He just saws it and moves it.
- Blake was so, early on in
the show, he'd be in L.A.
And he's such an Oklahoman
I mean, he really is.
He was miserable here before
he started fornicating with--
- Oh, my what?
(clapping)
(cheering)
- Here, here! (claps)
(clapping)
(cheering)
- [Carson] Thank God!
Thank you Gwen!
- So stupid!
- Thank you to Gwen!
But before Gwen-
- Blake does make her,
Gwen does make him happier (laughs).
- When we were in L.A.
it would be a mission
to try and find something
for the cowboy to do
'cause he was such a
fish out of water in L.A.
And so we had the idea, one day we went to
where he would, I thought, be comfortable.
and I took him to an
old, to a Bass Pro Shop.
(laughing)
You know that, and I--
- Favorite shop in the world.
- That Pro Shop is great!
- Walking around with Blake
Shelton as a Bass Pro Shop
was like walking around with
Jesus Christ at the Vatican
(clapping)
(laughing)
like his people are there!
He was very at home,
- We found each other.
he's like "I'm comfortable here!"